los países de la Unión Europea han dado
luz verde definitiva a una de las
medidas estrella en la lucha contra el
cambio climático el fin de los vehículos
con gasolina y diésel a partir de 2035 a
partir de esta fecha ningún coche de
Nueva matriculación que emita dióxido de
carbono podrá circular dentro de la
Unión Europea esta medida se propuso por
la comisión europea hace dos años Aunque
en las últimas semanas se había
debido a que Alemania y otros
países querían más garantías de que
coches Como por ejemplo con tecnología
de hidrocarburos sintéticos pudieran
seguir circulando también a partir de
2035 este tipo de tecnología es muy
residual apenas se utiliza pero algunos
fabricantes como porcho BMW han apostado
por este tipo de tecnología la de los
hidrocarburos sintéticos Alemania
asegura que puede ser un nuevo foco de
innovación que también de creación de
puestos de trabajo esta tecnología como
comentábamos es muy residual y muy cara
pero Alemania asegura que es neutra en
carbono aunque las organizaciones
ecologistas aseguran que también emiten
partículas contaminantes en cualquier
caso la comisión europea asegurado que
este tipo de coches podrá seguir
circulando a partir de 2035 pero deben
ser neutros en carbono Y así conseguir
el objetivo de que en 2050 la Unión
Europea sea la primera Región
climáticamente neutra del mundo